I know when I was starting to Vlog I
started writing my top three priorities
for the day now so I got this white
board and I got it from Target for like
12.99 and I had it up in my office for
the longest I didn't know what to write
on it and one day I was like you know
what I would just write my top three
priorities I clearly saw that there was
a need that there were other
procrastinators like me who like to over
plan and couldn't execute I ended up
creating the top three notebook we've
sold over fifty thousand dollars worth
of top three notebooks since we created
them and it's just nuts to know that
this all came from me vlogging